the supreme court is moving into its
busy season with
two major end of the term decisions and
several more on the way
the justices ruled unanimously yesterday
that philadelphia's foster care program
cannot exclude a catholic agency that
does not allow same-sex couples to take
in children
the court also rejected the latest
challenge to obamacare
ruling seven to two that a group of
states and two individuals
supported by the trump administration
had no legal standing to challenge the
health care law
jan crawford is at the supreme court
following it all
jan these are two big rulings big
rulings and really these were the first
controversial cases they've been taken
up by this newly conservative court with
of course
those three new justices appointed by
former president trump and i got to say
what was most surprising there was so
much agreement
ever since former president obama signed
the affordable care act the law has been
the center of a political shouting match
repeal and replace obamacare you have to
do it
conservatives have now taken three cases
to the supreme court
arguing the law should be thrown out for
millions
of americans this is very good news
on thursday the third case failed the
aca
is here to stay the decision found four
conservative justices siding with their
three more liberal colleagues
including amy coney barrett who was
attacked by democrats as a staunch
opponent of the law during her
confirmation
hard to think of another way of bringing
down the aca
jeffrey rosen president of the national
constitution center
said obamacare's opponents may be out of
legal options
there have been a lot of legal theories
already rejected in the courts
and there's likely not to be another
another swing at this particular bat
a second decision also featured
surprising agreement
all nine justices ruled unanimously that
the city of philadelphia was wrong to
end its contract with the catholic
foster care agency
because it refused to work with same-sex
couples
the battle over the balance between
lgbtq rights and religious liberty
will continue the court avoided the big
question rosen says the real takeaway
from these rulings is more fundamental
justices from stephen breyer to john
roberts have said they don't want
america to perceive the court as
political
and in these cases they prove that they
meant it by achieving
anonymity but next year i mean this
court is going to tackle some of the
most divisive and contentious
issues in our society they've got a case
on abortion rights gun rights possibly
affirmative action and it's also unclear
if this supreme court is even going to
look the same
progressives are urging liberal justice
stephen breyer who's 82 years old
to retire while democrats still control
the senate
his replacement would almost certainly
be more liberal
anthony all right jane crawford of the
supreme court jan
thank you